it's the weirdest [__] ever though like
cuz you like you can do like this and
you will fly like a dream huh like it
was sometimes I hit the wall too hard
trying cuz you can't swim you know what
I'm saying people think you can swim and
[__] in the air you can't swim boun you
do it like this you just be flipping
around and [__] so like if you touch
something that's how you push yourself
off mhm like imagine being in like space
space with the [__] spaceship right
and you go outside to change the engine
or some [__] and you push off the W too
hard it's over gone forever you're gone
you literally just going to die it's
crazy bro it's really crazy but it's
like you would never know that unless
you like go up there a lot and really be
experiencing that [__] you